[Music]
Congrats on the book yeah thanks you
know but uh yeah it was I mean it took
me three years from start to finish and
then it also just for your first one
there's so much learning that goes into
it like yeah it pretty much every part
of the process I'm flying blind and just
I'm learning as I go so there's that
once I call Hofstadter's law or it's
like everything takes twice as long as
you expect even if you take this into
account yeah oh my god the timelines on
this thing are insane you know so it's
quite it's quite something it's a huge
accomplishment the book is great and
excited to break it down with you yeah
cool thanks thanks for coming out here
today I think the best way to launch
into it is to define our terms I mean
let's talk about before we even get into
the nuances of all of this like let's
just define what a habit is sure so
there are a couple ways to think about
it but I would say just quick definition
a habit is a behavior that has been
repeated enough times to be performed
more or less automatically so you can do
it pretty much on autopilot but another
way to think about it I think this is a
useful way to define a habit is that as
you go through life you face different
problems and some of those problems are
big and some of them are small like you
needed tie your shoes and whenever you
face a problem your brain starts looking
for solutions to that and as you come
across solutions to the recurring
problems in life you start to automate
those and so every morning you wake up
and you put your shoes on and you got
this little problem that you need to
solve and pretty soon after you tie your
shoes a hundred times or five hundred
times or a thousand times you can do it
pretty much without thinking and so
that's another way of thinking about
habits is that they're kind of these
like automatic solutions we fall into
for whatever the recurring problems are
we face right behavior that becomes
habituated yeah and you know like
they're the interesting thing about this
is you don't necessarily have to have
the same habit to solve a recurring
problem like if you come home from work
each day and you feel stressed and
exhausted
one person might play video games for an
hour and that's a way to resolve
problem so they get in the habit of
doing and they just walk over the
controller that I'm think about it
another person might go for a run for 20
minutes or meditate for 10 minutes third
person might smoke a cigarette and all
of those are just solutions to that
problem that you're facing and that I
think is another powerful lesson is that
your original habit is not necessarily
the optimal one and once you realize
that then it kind of becomes your
responsibility to become a little more
aware of what those habits are and think
about can you shape them or design them
right and so a habit is the physical
manifestation it's a behavior a physical
manifestation of your psychological
makeup your your emotional body and your
conscious or unconscious mind right like
habits flow from what is already built
inside of us on some level right so to
kind of deconstruct what a habit is how
to change it what's a good habit what's
a bad habit how to flow from good to bad
good it it demands I would imagine and
you're the expert here you know a real
analysis of like how our brains function
you have to look at psychology you have
to look at neurology you have to look at
the science and understand the human
mechanism in its holistic form I think
that's true and you bring up a really
interesting point and one that I wanted
to answer or think about in the book
because the so in the book I lay out
this four stage model for how habits
work and the reason the second stage is
there it's all about craving and
prediction in other words like you come
across a cue or some kind of context and
then you interpret it in a certain way
and that's where we're getting to this
point that you're just making which is
that the habit only comes after the
habit is the behavior that follows your
prediction or your interpretation of how
you should act in a given context and
you know for one person they might see
their couch as the place where they read
for an hour each night and so their
interpretation of that context is I
should open up a book for another person
they might see the couch as the place
where they turn on Netflix for an hour
and eat a bowl of ice cream and so
that's a different interpretation of the
same physical cue and so in that way
habits kind of follow their this
lagging measure of how you predict you
should respond to the different context
now yeah and I like how you couch it in
the context of of habits being a
solution to a problem they're not the
problem themselves necessarily they're a
reflection of what's going on inside of
us their solution to whatever emotional
state it is I mean a habit is a way of
adapting to an environment or solving a
problem yes right yeah it's a way of
solving a recurring problem you come
over it again and again and then pretty
soon you're falling into that that
pattern right so a lot has been written
about habit change you know you go to
any bookstore certainly in the airports
there's no shortage of of self-help
primers on how to change our behaviors
how to develop healthy effective habits
and now you're kind of coming into this
sphere with a little bit of a different
perspective so maybe it would make sense
to kind of canvass conventional wisdom
on on habit change and and perhaps your
like different take on how we approach
this sure so I mean I think there are a
variety of little insights in the book
that are maybe different or just a
slightly slightly different angle on on
the common takes but I'll just go over
some of the big ones real quick so there
are many different fields I draw it on
for the book and I think that I like to
call myself idea agnostic and what I
mean is I don't really care where a good
idea comes from as long as it's a good
idea or practical or useful so nervous
science biology psychology and so on but
the most common area that people talk
about habits in is psychology and there
are kind of two big movements or bodies
of research that have happened over the
last hundred years
the first was behavioral psychology and
so this started with classical
conditioning like Pavlov's dogs and
things like that and then BF Skinner's
work with kind of a cue like the light
would go on and sign the little suitcase
right and then the rat would press a
lever and then they'd get a pellet and
so this kind of linking the pellet to
the light and so you have a cue and then
a
response than a reward and Skinner
defined this as stimulus response reward
so once you start to link the cue to the
reward they realize they could shape
pretty much any kind of action and do
Higgs book power of habit and kind of
popularized this and brought it back
into the modern spotlight and this idea
of a cue routine their reward so that's
the first kind of major area the second
is cognitive psychology and this kind of
took often like the 50s and 60s and has
continued into the modern day but the
psychologists started playing with what
Skinner put together and realize that
well it wasn't just the cue and the
reward that shaped people's behavior
also our thoughts and moods and emotions
our beliefs kind of our internal states
shaped behavior - and this was a
question that I kind of had rolling
around in my mind when I started working
on atomic habits was well how come the
same person will respond to the same cue
in a different way at different times
you know like if I if I walk into the
kitchen and I see a plate of cookies
it's like a visual cue and in one case I
might be like oh those look good I
should go eat them but you can just as
easily imagine a situation where I just
finished eating dinner in the other room
and I walk in and I see a plate of
cookies and I'm like oh I'm stuffed I
don't want to eat anything so what's
going on there the cue is the same the
reward is the same why aren't you taking
the same action and I think it's because
of that internal process you're
interpreting the cue differently based
on your current state and so the model
that I lay out in the book of the four
different stages that I have it goes
through it tries to combine these two
major fields it includes the cue and the
reward because those are important for
shaping our behavior but it also
includes an additional stage about our
interpretation of the reward because
your internal moods and states and
feelings can change and as they do your
behavior does as well and so I kind of
wanted to model that I felt like
encapsulated all of that and that's one
of the major difference right so you
added two steps to this now it's cue
craving response for reward right right
and so that allows you to kind of more
deeply probe into
that that aspect of contextualizing
these cues it actually brings up to I
think important things so the first is
the contextualizing bit cue which you
just mentioned it allows us to
understand like why do you why to ques
get you to do anything it's because of
how you interpret them if you believe
the cue is attractive then you take an
action the second thing that it does is
it helps clarify what the reward is like
why is something rewarding why do you
find it rewarding and one of the reasons
is because it satisfies the craving that
preceded the action so one way to put
this is that perceived value motivates
you to act actual value motivates you to
repeat so it when you buy something on
Amazon you don't actually buy the
product like you don't you don't buy the
book because you don't actually have it
yet what you buy is the image the
product creates in your mind you buy
your expectation or the perceived value
of the sales page it's only after you
get the book and you read it and you're
like oh this is really good
that's when the actual value it
satisfies that craving you have before
and it reinforces oh hey this was
enjoyable I should do it again next time
so you kind of have both of those on on
each side of the the behavior cravings
that generally derive from very primal
instinctual reptilian brain instincts
that we have I mean typically and these
function on an unconscious level and in
almost everybody I mean when you're when
you're surfing Amazon and you hit by on
something like you said it's not it's
not necessarily driven by this interest
in this product advancing you along your
trajectory it's probably more likely
because you feel uncomfortable in that
moment and the dopamine rush of buying
that thing will make you feel you know
what will change your emotional state
and give you some sense of comfort
driven by your hormonal state right and
this goes back you know you talked about
this in the book the book and in the
writing that you do like we want people
to love us we want to be perceived well
by others
or we think these material things are
gonna you know fulfill that that
spiritual hole that we have you know our
emotional need and all these drivers
function on a level where we're not
really aware of how they're impacting
our behaviors and habits throughout the
day so how do you kind of think about
those things well in a sense you could
say that every behavior is driven by the
desire for a change in state and so when
you smoke a cigarette or eat a bag of
Doritos or pick up your phone what you
really want is not the nicotine or the
calories from the Doritos or the the
likes on social media what you want is
to feel less anxious or to feel approved
or to not be bored anymore so it's
really the desire to change that state
that you're in that motivates you to act
and the behavior and in many cases a lot
of our modern technology as an example
this you didn't we didn't evolve you
didn't come out of the womb with like a
desire to check Instagram right like
there's nothing evolutionarily wired
there it's just a modern manifestation
of an ancient desire to gain respect and
approval or to not be abandoned by the
tribe or to feel approved and you know
in some of the capacity and so we kind
of have those like deeper primal drives
and then the secondary layer on top of
it is just the modern manifestation of
that behavior and how we're resolving it
in the moment yeah I mean it's really
it's interesting that the the more this
is like a subject matter that's so
important because the habits that
comprise how we behave and navigate our
day are determinative of our entire
experience as a human being not only do
they determine whether we're going to be
you know quote-unquote successful or
failures they literally dictate every
aspect of our of our experience as
humans so on some level like there is no
subject more important and really
understanding how behaviors work so I
applaud you for taking on such a
monumental
like this is not easy to understand and
I think also it's it's um it's something
that that we can easily kind of fall
prey to intellectualizing and feeling
like okay I understand this but yet
still find ourselves incapable of
actually implementing the knowledge into
the behavior change that you're trying
to you know sort of speak about and and
instigate in people hmm yeah well so
first of all I totally agree it was an
incredibly difficult topic to choose
especially for my first book I ended up
my solution was just try to like work
harder at it I there was a there was a
quote from Elaine de Bataan that kind of
became my my mantra as I worked through
where he says of many books a reader
thinks this could have been truly great
if only the author was willing to suffer
a little more I was like all right my
life mantra I guess I just need to
suffer a little more yeah but uh but
yeah I ended up writing I think like 720
750 pages and then cut it down to the
final 250 because it just it ended up
the scope of the behavior change and
human behavior is just so wide that you
know anyway I need I thought like I
needed to cover all the bases and then
figure out what are the actionable steps
and your point that it's easy to just
theorize or get kind of like mm caught
up in your head about this rather than
translating it into something actionable
I think that's a crucial thing and it's
one thing that I pride myself on my
writing is that I try to be
scientifically based but also highly
actionable and that was the idea of
behind the four laws of behavior change
that are in the book cuz I wanted to
kind of give people up like a set of
levers or a toolbox that okay here like
the four levers you can pull to try to
make habits easier or to make bad habits
harder yeah and I want to get into those
those for those four laws but before we
do that why don't we I want to I'm
interested in what got you interested in
this subject matter to begin with I find
that most people
who you know walk that path of becoming
obsessed with a certain subject matter
or idea tend to be people who are trying
to solve that equation for themselves so
is that part of the influence in a sense
every article i've written and this book
is just a reminder to myself hmm my
publisher told me there's something to
the effect of like we write the books we
need ourselves and that's it's funny
because you know when I write about
habits a lot of people assume that I
have my habits so dialed in because I'm
the guy writing them right but I'm
writing about it to learn about it you
know I'm writing about it to try to
improve I consider my readers and myself
to be Pearce right we're all just kind
of experimenting and operating and
working on stuff and the only difference
is I just share the lessons when I
learned them so yeah I I definitely had
an internal desire for that and then
there have been a variety of areas in my
life where I've had to implement that
athletics photography writing and
building a business of course and all of
those have been kind of like test labs
for me to put the ideas under prep right
so y0 went on this on habits yeah well i
think that a little bit of it comes back
to what you just mentioned a few minutes
ago about how important habits are I
didn't know this at first so I was a
baseball player for many years and as
any athlete can tell you there are all
kinds of habits that you have a practice
rituals things like that and I was
benefiting from that you know my
strength coach would tell me to do
something or my coaches would hold me
accountable to certain habits and that
would help pull the rest of my life in
line you know I always did better in
school when I had sports as well it
would it would like give me something to
anchor my day around and so I knew that
it was working but I didn't have a
language for it and so it was only until
maybe five years after my career ended
and I finished graduate school and I
started like looking into this stuff a
little bit more that I started to come
across the science of habit formation
and behavior change and developed a
language for it and started write about
it so I kind of implicitly know it was
important but didn't discover that the
actual way to write about until later
now the second thing here though is
that I as I dug into the topic more I
started like unearth these layers and
realized wow this is actually even more
important than I thought and this comes
back to the point that you made a few
minutes ago which is that habits are one
of the phrases I'd like to use is that
pretty much any of the results in your
life are a lagging measure of your
habits right so you're right weight as a
lagging measure of your eating habits
your bank account as a lagging measure
of your financial habits your clutter is
a lagging measure of your cleaning
habits like the outcomes are just the
the manifestation of the behaviors that
preceded them right so you kind of get
what you repeat in that way well that
makes sense people understand that
that's important so that's one reason
why habits are crucial but there's
another thing that habits do that is
even more central even more important
and that is that your habits are the way
that you embody a particular identity so
every morning that you make your bed you
embody the habits of you embodied the
identity of an organized person someone
who's clean every time you go to the gym
you embody the identity of someone who
is fit every time you sit down to write
a sentence or a page you embody the
identity of someone who's a writer and
so in that sense habits are like every
action you take is kind of like a vote
for the type of person that you believe
that you are and as you take these
actions you build up evidence of a
particular identity and pretty soon your
beliefs have something to like root
themselves and it's like man you know
I've showed up at the gym for four days
a week for the last three months I guess
like I'm the type of person who doesn't
miss workouts and that I think is the
true reason what habits are so important
once I realized how beliefs and
behaviors are connected that it's like
this two-way street then I've started to
think alright maybe this is really
something not only does it deliver those
external results the clean room or the
you know bigger bank account but also
the internal results of shaping your
sense of self image and what you believe
right so let's drill into these four
laws you've got we'll just break them
down
okay so I've hinted at this process so
far but the four stages that any habit
goes through cue
craving response reward so there's some
type of cue or raw data that gets your
attention
then you predict or interpret that data
in some way which motivates you to act
take a response and then somehow that
behavior either benefits you or does not
benefit you and that's what gets you to
close the feedback loop and update your
prediction for the next time and decide
if you want to continue that although a
caveat to that I would imagine is that
there is a rule you're saying it either
benefits you or it doesn't but isn't
there an argument that it's it's
benefiting you somehow maybe not in a
good way but you're getting something
out of that like if you have a habit
that's unhealthy some bad behavior and
everybody tells you you got to stop
doing that
you're you're getting some positive
result from that even if it's twisted
you know or unhealthy there's something
inside of you that compels you to act
that way because because you're getting
something out of it right so that's
actual point yeah like it whether it's
masking some pain or whatever it is
there there's a reason behind that all
behaviors those that are repeated
service in some way I guess we'd say all
habits serve you in some way yeah and
one way to think about this is that
every behavior produces multiple
outcomes across time so if you take a
bad habit or an unhealthy habit like
eating a doughnut or something the
immediate outcome is favorable but
sugary it's tasty it's enjoyable in the
moment that's how it serves you that's
the reason why you repeat it the
ultimate outcome if you repeat that
every day for the next three months or
year or whatever is you end up gaining
weight or you're less healthy or so on
for good habits it's often the reverse
right like sometimes you know the
benefit of going to the gym in many
people's eyes is the immediate outcomes
unfavorable sweat I have to work it's
effortful it's hard and sacrifice I
don't get to watch TV I got to go there
instead these Savini the outcome is
unfavorable the ultimate outcome if you
repeat that habit for two months or a
year or whatever is you're fit and
healthy and this is one of the key
challenges of building good habits and
breaking bad ones is figuring out ways
to take the long-term consequences of
your good habits or of your bad habits
and
pull them into the present moment so you
feel a little bit of the pain right now
so it serves you less and to take the
long-term rewards of your good habits
and pull those into the present moment
so it feels good
this is one reason why you know it's
great to choose like what's the best
form of exercise
well maybe it's about the one that you
enjoy because if it feels good in the
moment now it serves you you have a
reason to repeat it yeah humans are not
wired to prioritize long term rewards
over immediate gratification Ren that's
why you know habit change in the
interest of setting you on a long term
positive trajectory is much more
difficult than defaulting to the
immediate gratification that's leading
you astray and intellectualization of it
doesn't really help no it's not like
everybody who's smoking knows it's bad
for them yes yeah but they can't you
know they can't stop even though the
long-term benefits of stopping are
evident and indisputable for some reason
we lack the ability to harness that
motivation to implement that behavior
change I so I think that's a good way to
define what a good habit is and what a
bad habit is is that bad habits think
about it in the long term good habits
serve you in the long run
bad habits do not even if they serve you
in the moment and so yes they're sorry
to interrupt you but is there is there
an argument to be had that that we would
be benefited from removing judgment on
habits altogether and and and kind of
avoid classifying them as good or bad
into saying these are behaviors they're
serving you in a certain way like let's
take all the passion and emotion out of
this altogether and look at it from just
a forensic point of view would that be a
good way of helping people I don't know
make that make the transition from one
to the other have you looked at that I
think so and part of the reason is that
in order to change behavior design it in
any meaningful way you need to be aware
of it first but usually when people
become aware of their habits or think
about them you know like you might smoke
or bite your nails or something on
autopilot but then if you start to think
about it well you
guilty about it you know you start to
judge yourself as soon as you start to
judge yourself then you're not in a
great position to change because you
what ends up happening a lot of the time
this has happened actually with a couple
campaigns that have tried to scare
smokers into not smoking by showing them
pictures of blackened lungs or scare
obese people into not eating as much by
talking about the the detriments of
being overweight what happens is people
get really anxious and stress they feel
guilty and worried and then they resort
amplify they resort to their preferred
habit for dealing with that which means
they end up smoking more eating more or
whatever so yes I think there is a
benefit to looking at it in an
unemotional forensic way and one way to
do that is to say there are no good or
bad habits there are just behaviors that
serve you in a particular way and the
goal is to try to find a behavior that
serves you in a better way and I still
use the term good and bad because I
think implicitly most people know what
we're talking about when we say that
like and we use it in everyday
conversation but from a practical
standpoint it's just in the the effort
and energy used judging yourself and
feeling guilty about things is not well
spent or productive and so if that is a
way that helps people get over that that
I think that's useful yeah
there's also certainly a hierarchy of
habits to what I see a lot of and I'm
interested in in your experience working
with so many people on this is people
honing in zeroing in on a behavior a
habit that they want to change but
they're kind of identifying the wrong
one like if your goal is to lose 10
pounds or the behavior that you want to
change the habit that you want to change
is going from sedentary to being a
runner for example you're gonna run your
first 5k so this goal but you have a
victim mentality and you think the world
is against you and everything bad in
your life is somebody else's fault and
you're not addressing and redressing the
habits that are fueling that identity
you can run as many 5ks or marathons as
you want but ultimately you're
channeling
energy in a rough direction right yeah
the the energy is focused on like this
the thing that makes the last like 2% of
difference not the thing that makes 95%
of difference right you see this in all
kinds of places I mean the example you
just gave is good but just take someone
who's trying to get in shape I mean
people will what kind of protein powder
should I get what nice leaves do I need
what are the best weight lifting shoes
and all that stuff is like the last 2% a
difference that it's mostly like don't
miss workouts and get your reps in
yeah but ultimately I think that those
people aren't even really interested in
the answer they're just stuck in
analysis paralysis like they they sort
of want to change their behavior but
they want to have all these questions
answered and they want to know exactly
what they're doing before they'll even
go take a walk right so how much do they
really want to change that behavior
they're flirting with the idea of
behavior change but they're ultimately
not at the place where they're ready to
commit to anything and so that makes
them feel like they're doing something
when they're actually just reinforcing
that paralysis this is what in the book
I call the difference between motion and
action action can actually deliver a
result but motion is related to that but
never will you know like going to the
gym and talking to a personal trainer
about signing up that's fine that's
related to getting in shape but it
doesn't matter how many times you talk
to a personal trainer you're never gonna
get in shape whereas like doing 10
squats that actually can do something
that's like talking to the trainers
motion doing squats is action yeah and
yeah I think a lot of times people get
trapped in motion they get trapped in
analysis paralysis because it is a way
to feel like you're making progress
without running the risk of failure
right and it's it's more complicated and
nuanced than that because going and
talking to the trainer is an important
step if you've never done anything like
that before yeah that's the thing is
it's not like you shouldn't do it yeah
it's just that it's not the only thing
right if that if that's the thing if
that doesn't create the momentum to take
the additional step and and and set in
motion a consistent flow of repeatable
actions over time then this is why I
think identity
such a crucial issue with habits is that
true behavior changes really identity
change because you're not really looking
to go from the type of person who
doesn't run to the type of person who
can run a 5k that's fine that's good
it's the outcome but the goal is not to
run a marathon the goal is to become a
runner the goal is not to write a book
the goal is to become a writer and once
you identify as that type of person in a
sense you're not even really pursuing
behavior change anymore you're just
acting in alignment with the type of
person that you already believe that you
are right now it's like one thing to say
I want this it's something different to
say I am this yeah you write a lot about
this and and we can drill down on goals
and the importance or lack thereof of
goal-setting but ultimately what really
moves the needle is making a decision
about the person that you want to be and
starting to construct your life in a way
that reinforces that identity that you
idealize in yourself so it's less about
a finish line and it becomes all about
process and the journey I think that's
right you know like your what I said
earlier about how habits are method to
embody a particular identity that's
really what we're looking to do here is
how do I become the type of person that
embodies this each day how do I become
the type of person who doesn't miss
workouts and that's another reason I
like small habits because if you have a
really busy day and things are crazy and
all you can do is five push-ups if
you're oriented around the result around
the outcome it's easy to dismiss that so
why would I even bother doing five
push-ups it's not gonna get me in shape
but some days it's not about the result
of the training some days it's about
reinforcing being that type of person
you know like yes life was crazy and
things were really busy today and the
best I could do was getting five
push-ups in but I'm still the type of
person who doesn't miss workouts even
when it's not ideal right and in the
long run that can count for a lot which
is the kind of twisted thing about small
habits which is that even though they're
small they can still be meaningful and
if they're meaningful they actually are
big yeah and and that really gets at the
foundation of this whole thing which is
that every great achievement is
small habits ultimately and you know as
our a in this culture in which we live
it's all about you know shoot for the
moon and like set these huge goals and
be audacious and find the shortcut and
all of that but every successful person
will tell you it's about the tiny little
imperceptible non sexy things that they
do every single day and have been doing
for the last 10 or 20 years that got
them from wherever they came from to the
place that everyone aspires to be the
crazy thing is habits are habits like
the foundation for mastery in in any
area and it's often the people who are
at the peak of a particular area that
have the best habits that have like the
most things automated and dialed in you
know imagine I was think of the story of
Josh Waitzkin who wrote the art of
learning and his he gave an example of
he's doing you know tie push hands this
martial art and I when I think about
doing something like that I'm like
alright I'm gonna be grappling with this
person like ah you know I'm fully
engaged on the the wrestling component
but he had practiced it so many times
and knew all the moves so well that he
was able to more or less put that part
of it on autopilot and he would just
focus on his opponents eyes and when
they were getting ready to blink then he
would make us throw and that was like
how he found his advantage
that to someone like me who hasn't done
that that sounds insane that you could
even like get to that level but the
point is in order to master any area he
has already habitual eyes everything
else he knows how to do the throws on
autopilot he knows where his feet should
be on autopilot he knows where his
weight should be shifted and because all
of that is habitual eyes he actually has
the mental capacity available to focus
on the thing that makes the last tiniest
bit of difference at the highest level
yeah I think that's true for anybody you
know I mean think about everything
LeBron can do on autopilot I mean he
doesn't have to think about shooting
dribbling where he's out on the court
like all of that is just internalized at
this point and he can think about the
offensive set or the thing that happened
three possessions ago that he did to set
them up for what he's going to do now
but most basketball players aren't even
at that level because they haven't
habitual eyes yeah have you seen the
documentary free soul oh yeah that just
oh you saw it yeah yeah alright good so
for people that are that are listening
and haven't seen it you should go out
and see it immediately outside its Alex
Honnold free soloing El Cap and even if
you think you know the story I assure
you that this movie will leave you with
sweaty palms and your mind blown dude
those rock climbing documentaries are
crazy but this one is next-level and it
speaks the reason I bring it up is it
speaks directly to what you're talking
about which is a level of process and
mastery that is is rare even at the
highest levels and you think of Alex as
a master but when you really get to
understand the level of focus and
intentionality and the amount of years
that went into that accomplishment you
understand it on a whole different level
and you talk about automation I mean you
see when he's climbing that wall he
knows every every hold every every
maneuver every footstep and there's
actually only maybe three or four
problem areas up the whole wall that he
really had to double down on to make it
work and all the rest of it was so wrote
for him and if you were to ask him you
know he's he doesn't have to he's not
he's not intellectualizing this you know
it's it's so built into who he is that
that the execution of climbing that wall
is just a reflection of a lifetime of
preparation and focus that's followed in
the wake of that success with him going
back to his van and doing pull-ups you
know because he is somebody that's who
he is it's identity
it wasn't about yes he had that goal and
the goal was audacious and he was
successful in that goal but he was he
was successful in that pursuit because
this is who he is
fundamentally at his core I remember
hearing a story about Brett Favre with
late in his career and there was a
particular crossing pattern this guy's
running across the field and the
linebacker was interviewed after the
game who was defending against the pass
and he was like 999 times out of a
thousand every time this play is run
based on my positioning the pass is
going to be going in front of the
backer and so he saw the play and read
it and jumped up to intercept the pass
and Favre somehow implicitly noticed all
of this and threw it behind him and hit
the receiver and stride in the end up
getting the first down in this big play
right happening in a microsecond yes all
of this is you know it for the average
person you'd stand out there in the
middle of the play and just would look
like chaos there who is moving around so
fast and the stories like that and like
Alex and and these other ones that were
telling the only way that you can get to
that level of the only way he could even
notice that is because every other thing
about that play was already on autopilot
he had run it so many times that he
could see the one thing that was
different and make the adjustment on the
fly and those stories of course are
incredible and inspiring but they also
make me realize that I don't know many
people fully understand what it takes to
be at the top of a field like that to
you have to literally live it so that
you can internalize all that stuff I
mean the higher that you get on the
curve it's like the less margin for
error that there is and you need to work
I mean Olympians will work for four
years to shave off to hundreds of a
second and that you have to have that
level of commitment because the when
you're going against the world's best
the margin is so small and yeah anyway I
think habits play a central role in that
I think right they are they are crucial
because the more that you can habitual
eyes the more you free up your mind to
focus on the things that could make that
last bit of difference so let's talk
about how to change we were attempting
to launch into these four laws and we
haven't even gotten there break these
down okay so there are four laws of
behavior change make it obvious so
that's about the cue make it attractive
that's about the craving make it easy
this is the response and then make it
satisfying which is the reward and this
is all about adopting a quote unquote
good hap correct and then you can invert
each of those four for breaking a bad
habit so for a bad habits you want to
make it invisible and make the cue
invisible and make it unattractive make
it difficult and make it unsatisfying
and again these are like a toolbox for
thinking about what can we practically
do on a daily basis for building good
habits and breaking bad ones
so obvious so one way to think about
this is with a strategy that I call
environment design and the idea is just
to restructure your physical environment
to make the cues of your good habits
obvious and the cues of your bad habits
invisible so let me give you an example
both these are two personal examples so
I first I realized that for most of my
life have brushed my teeth brushed my
teeth twice a day but I wouldn't floss
consistently and when I looked at the
habit there were two issues and one of
the problems was the floss was just
tucked away in the drawer in the
bathroom I wouldn't see it and so
because it wasn't obvious sometimes I
just would forget the second thing
sounds kind of silly but I didn't like
the feeling of wrapping floss around my
fingers it was just like uncomfortable
and so anyway I took the floss out of
the drawer bought a little bowl and got
some of those pre-made philosophers and
put them in the bowl and set it right
next to my toothbrush and now I brush my
teeth put the toothbrush down pick a
floss hurry up do it right away
it's obvious and that's pretty much all
I needed to do to build that habit now
I've been doing it for I don't know five
years and never really had to think
about it this is the most important
thing I think there's a lot of people my
friend Dan Buettner included who don't
hold a lot of confidence and belief in a
single human beings ability to to
implement positive behavior changes with
sustainable as old long-term results
it's just that's why there's so many
self-help books people struggle with
weight and fitness and you know you name
it profession like all of these things
it's so hard but the best way to
fundamentally address these things is to
change your environment so that it's
conducive to the healthy choice so
whether it's flossing your teeth or re
reimagining what an urban landscape is
so that's incentivizing people to ride
their bikes and not drive cars and not
drink sodas but drink water like
structural systemic changes in our
environment that make the Healthy Choice
the the productive choice not only the
obvious choice but
in some cases the only choice or the
choice that is at arm's length at all
times and that goes with eradicate
eradicating the unhealthy choices
removing those from arm's reach so that
they become more difficult to access yes
it's huge I mean imagine the impact of
living in an environment where or
working in an environment where there
are a hundred little things like that
they're all kind of nudging you in the
right direction or nudging you away from
the wrong direction here's another
example for breaking a bad habit so
again here you just invert it rather
than make it obvious make it invisible
I've noticed that if I buy a six-pack of
beer and I put it in the front of the
fridge like either in the door or like
right in the front of the shelf I'll
open it up and I'll have one each night
just because it's there but if I take it
and I put it in the back of the fridge
like lowest shelf all the way in the
back where I can't really see it when I
open the door sometimes it'll sit there
for like a month and so it's interesting
you know I'm like what did I do I want a
beer or not because in a way I do but
only if it's really presented to me I
moved it like five inches yes really
seriously it was probably like yeah it's
probably 12 inches back well I could
tell you as a recovering alcoholic my
drinking days that would not have been
there I would have had to take more
extreme measures so that actually raises
a good point which is that many of these
strategies that talk about in the book
are very effective for good habits and
bad habits even though we just agreed
not to use that term but not necessarily
for true addictions yeah and this is
something I wanted to really get into
with you which is the difference the
qualitative difference between a quote
unquote bad habit and something that
would qualify as an addiction I think
that line gets blurred and certainly
it's a spectrum but I think there's a
very different approach that you need to
take when somebody is truly you know
falling prey to addictive behavior
patterns versus something that's just
habituated yeah so we'll get back to the
four laws behavior Nike by the end of
this we will gather so the technical
definition for an addiction and by the
way I don't consider myself an expert on
addiction
is a behavior that you continue to
repeat despite negative consequences so
you know that it's bad for you you know
it's not serving you but you still can't
stop yourself from doing it and those I
do agree it's probably on a spectrum so
you know on one side of the spectrum you
have a behavior that you do just one
time and then the more that you repeat
it you car - if down and then at some
point maybe you cross over this
threshold you get to a habit and then if
you go even further
you've got behaviors that you keep doing
again and again but you don't learn from
them and we'll call that an addiction
and so it's kind of like the feedback
loop is broken you go through the queue
you have the craving you take the
response but then instead of there being
a reward instead of it's serving you in
some way
really all it does is just satisfy the
craving and it did but it's not good for
the rest of your life the feedback loop
isn't necessarily broken it's just that
it doesn't matter mm-hmm you know the
cravings addicted is is typically I mean
there's you know again denial as a
spectrum as well but on some level
whether conscious or unconscious they're
aware that they're destroying their
lives but it simply doesn't matter
they're still going to pursue this path
of destruction no matter where it takes
them and I can just tell you from my own
personal experience as somebody who has
always prided themselves on having a
large capacity to endure work somebody
who has a you know a reservoir of
self-will who had been successful in
many ways by virtue of a strong worth
that work ethic I was confounded and
brought to my knees time and time again
by my inability to leverage these skills
that I thought were my secret weapons to
this problem and the more that I applied
self-will determination decision-making
power my ability to dedicate myself to a
goal the deeper that hole got like I had
to completely upend how I saw the world
and come to this place of not just
acceptance and breaking that veil of
denial but also surrender like
understanding that I was power
/ this thing was really the first base
of trying to figure out a new trajectory
forward and it's very counterintuitive
and weird and it doesn't make sense to
most people unless you've gone through
this process it's like a letting go as
opposed to like a like some sort of
driven willingness to like fight it so
it was like you could apply
determination and grit to any other
every other area of my life I've had
success using those skills but for some
reason and this with this yeah it just
it made it worse and worse and worse and
worse yeah that's nice
further and further isolated me from
everybody else because I thought I can
solve this I don't need help I'm gonna
do this um you know I all these other
areas of my life have worked out when I
use this strategy there's no reason why
this strategy won't work here and it
just destroyed me hmm so I mean
obviously addiction is very complicated
and I don't know that so I just made the
distinction of the strategies in the
book I think are really good for bad
habits not necessarily for addictions
although I don't think that it would
hurt for to use those strategies for
addiction but I don't know that it's
gonna be like a little magic would solve
the problem well it may help with the
denial part at a very minimum mm-hmm
yeah so there's a secret chapter to the
book that's not included in the final
manuscript but that you can get at
atomic Abuse calm and it's called the
biology of bad behavior and it discusses
what scientists are doing to kind of
rewire the brain of addicts so some of
them are pills like cocaine addicts are
using a drug called baclofen that was
originally developed for back spasms
that some addicts say when they start to
take it suddenly their cravings in
addiction like have vanished more or
less overnight I don't know that it
works for all of them and that's kind of
the story with a lot of these drugs for
addiction right now is that some people
have really amazing results but not
every patient does then there's a second
strategy has been National Geographic
covered it last year it's starting to be
used in Italy and I think it's making
its way around the world where it's this
TMS machine this magnetic stimulation
for the brain and essentially the if I
as I understand it the prefrontal court
- the brain is responsible for a variety
of decision-making centers and your
ability to like resist temptation and in
addicts they find that this particular
area is kind of deactivated to a certain
degree and so when a craving arises you
have trouble resisting and so you'll go
in for this magnetic stimulation and
effectively they place the magnet over
that portion or that region of the brain
stimulate the neurons there with some
electrical impulses and people walk out
and they feel like they don't have
cravings anymore
yeah which is kind of crazy so I don't I
don't know where this is gonna go and I
I'm very wary to say that like oh this
is a magic trick and yeah I mean I think
all of that is interesting and I and
it's gonna be really cool to see how
this stuff plays out there's all kinds
of amazing studies happening with
psychedelics at the moment and treating
addicts with that but I always kind of
default to this you know fundamental
perspective that you know addiction is
fueled as gap our motto would say from
some kind of childhood trauma or some
psychological framework where a person
feels broken in some regard and is
compelled to engage in that destructive
addictive behavior as a means of state
change right which is what we were
talking about earlier so you can
eliminate the craving and eliminate the
behavior or the substance but that
predisposition remains and it will
continue to find another avenue to
satisfy itself with some kind of
behavior or whatever to solve whatever
that wound is or or that that sense of
incompleteness or inadequacy or whatever
it is that is that is really the driver
behind the addictive behavior because
the the substance or the behavior is the
solution to the problem and you can and
until it becomes the problem itself and
you can remove that but you're still
left with that fundamental disposition
that needs to get addressed
do you feel like running or writing has
been or something else has been the
thing that's there for you yeah they're
they're helpful and they're curative in
some regard but ultimately they're not
the solution for me I mean I
you know I've been sober for a long time
12 steps the secret society you know is
that's how I've yeah got sober and have
States over and I'm still you know and a
very very active member of that program
and that to this day is still my number
one priority and the minute I start to
lose sight of that or forget that or
take it for granted is when I start to
lapse back into into that realm and
there's no stasis either and you know
this is something you write about and
understand well like there's no like oh
I conquered that now I'm moving on to
this with addiction it's it's it's
either regressing or progressing with
every thought you entertain or behavior
that you engage in so you have to be
very mindful of it and engaged in the
behaviors and the activities that keep
it at bay in order to be healthy and
functional so I don't go around thinking
about drinking or using drugs very often
it rarely occurs to me but I have a
whole battery of other negative behavior
patterns that will manifest all kinds of
character defects that I wouldn't
qualify as addictions but our habits
that you know I'm constantly trying to
master or change yeah
well this is kind of an interesting
intersection with the second law to
bring it back to some of those because
so the first law we talked about make it
obvious and doing some of these
environment design changes the second
law is about making it attractive and
what I mean by that is when you
interpret a behavior excuse me when you
interpret a behavior or cue as being
attractive as being something you should
move toward then you have a reason to
perform the action and you're motivated
to do it so in many cases the behaviors
that are motivating to us that are
attractive to us are dependent on the
people that we are around so one way to
think about this is that we are all
members of tribes some of the tribes are
big some of them are small like big ones
might be what it means to be American or
what it means to be French or something
like that
and small ones could be you know what it
means to be a neighbor on your street or
a member of your local CrossFit gym or a
volunteer at your local
Highschool or whatever but all of these
tribes large and small have a set of
shared expectations that for what it
means to be part of the group and when
you belong to that tribe when you have
friends there when you feel like you
want to fit in with that group habits
that align with the shared expectations
of the tribe are very attractive and you
want to do them and habits that go
against the grain of the shared
expectations are very unattractive and
so one of the ways to make habits more
attractive is to join a group where your
desired behaviors the normal behavior to
be with a crew where the habits that you
want to build are just normal in every
day--for yeah I mean that's that's
really an extrapolation of the first law
you're extending your physical you're
creating a productive physical
environment and now you're extending
that to your interpersonal environment
so you're surrounding yourself with a
physical environment that's conducive to
the healthy behavior the healthy habit
and now you're surrounding yourself with
the people that reinforce that and make
it more difficult for you to behave
otherwise I mean society leans heavily
on all of us you know like I mean
there's a bunch of habits that people do
each day you don't even think about like
you get onto the elevator and you turn
around to face the front or you you uh
made that roll anyway yeah I know right
you go to a job interview yeah and you
wear a suit and tie or a dress or
something nice there's no reason it has
to be like that right like you could
face the back of the elevator you could
wear a bathing suit to a job interview
but we don't do that because it violates
those shared expectations it goes
against the grain of the group and so so
many of our choices are like that and in
many ways when we're young a lot of our
habits are not chosen they're inherited
they're passed down to us by whatever
group that we're a part of and then you
know part of the process of becoming an
adult as you grow up and you get into
your 20s and 30s and you decide these
groups that I inherited these behaviors
that I in here are these the ones that
serve me or these are the ones that I
want and then you know you kind of go
through the process of of changing that
and in many ways asking people to change
their habits is actually asking them to
change their tribe and that that can be
hard as
especially if you have to do it on your
own you know I mean that's one of the it
helps to have a new tribe to go to
because if people have to choose between
having the habits they want and being
alone or having the habits they don't
want and being with people being having
friends belonging we'd often rather be
wrong with the crowd than right by
ourselves yeah and I think we're seeing
this being played out culturally in this
interesting moment that we're having
right now we're across all forms of
social media the things that people are
saying in the political sphere are as
much signaling to their own group to
reaffirm their position within their
tribe as they are an attempt to convert
somebody from another tribe which
doesn't work generally but it's
interesting to see that social dynamic
writ large and because it's at such a
heightened state right now but it's
really no different than the guy who you
know was hanging out with his gym
buddies and wants to be part of that
crowd and and really wet himself in into
that subculture and identify with that
and be approved of by that group I wrote
an article recently called why facts
don't change our minds and humans need a
reasonably accurate view of the world of
the facts to survive you know like if
you couldn't accurately see where the
car was moving down the road and then
you walked out you get hit by one and
wouldn't past your jeans long and so on
and so you need to have some reasonable
baseline but within that there's
actually a fair bit of flexibility and
so people don't just hold beliefs
because they're true and accurate and
factual they also hold beliefs because
they can help them belong because they
signal to their social allies that hey I
belong to this tribe and in many cases
being abandoned by the tribe is more of
a death sentence than having a belief
that is slightly inaccurate that
especially one that doesn't impact your
personal life right now and so then we
fast-forward to modern society and you
get this manifesting and
kinds of rays right right right alright
well on this on this idea of making it
attractive and and surrounding yourself
with with the people that that affirm
and approve of and and encourage the
kind of behavior that you're trying to
manifest within yourself there are two
it seems to me there are two kind of
operating systems here there is the the
positive reinforcement that you get the
approval mechanism but there's also the
negative accountability right like if
because if you stray then you're gonna
be held accountable for that in the same
way you're gonna get a pat on the back
for toeing the line or being part of the
group right is there one that you've
seen that is more powerful than the
other are they both necessary how does
that work yeah that's that's a tough
question jonathan hate that I think he's
at NYU he has some interesting research
on this and I don't know that he's
performed with himself but he was the
one that I saw presented about the
importance of punishments and
consequences in societies in general and
like we need to know that there is a
punishment for breaking the law or
something in order for people to stay on
course yeah and so I'm not sure exactly
how that applies to habits my gut in
reaction is that you probably need both
in the long run but that extreme
punishments and consequences those like
fear-driven consequences rather than
rewards really get people to move in the
intermediate in the short term and
belonging and the positive rewards are
more likely to sustain standing long
time yeah so I would say that's
generally how I would bucket them I
think it was Tim Ferriss who came up
with that case study experiment of
creating a gym where I think I think the
idea was you pay all the money upfront
for the year and they take a picture of
you without your shirt on looking
terrible and if you don't if you miss a
day or whatever like then that image
goes on social media you know so this is
sort of like the stick you know yeah
being more powerful than the carrot at
least in the short term
I've heard about ones where they you pay
like you know I don't know what the
exact number would be maybe it's like
$150 a month and then every time you go
to the gym you get five bucks and so and
go everyday for 30 days you pay nothing
and you know if you go three days a week
you get two so that's kind of similar
incentive in the book I think I have an
example of this guy Thomas Frank he's
this entrepreneur in Colorado and he
wanted to build the habit of waking up
earlier and so he created a little
automated Twitter post that would go out
at 6 a.m. every morning or 6:05 I think
he wanted to wake up at 6 a.m. and so if
he didn't get up at 6 at 6:05 it would
posted Twitter and say I'm not up right
now because I'm lazy the first five
people to respond to this I'll pay pay
you $25 and and so then every day to
wake up at 6:00 and the first thing you
do is push that back to the next day
yeah that's a genius I mean you
definitely would wake up you know you
had some horrible tweet going out that
reflected poorly on you and yeah the
other example that comes to mind is the
I think it's Tim Ferriss as well which
was the if you fail like a certain
amount of money goes to an organization
that you despise their variety of
services you do that now that's called
beeminder
another one is called stick I think it's
STI CKK
but yeah you put like you know all right
my goal is run this half marathon and if
I don't train three days a week then I'm
putting $500 on the line and you commit
it and you can't get the money back
unless your friend releases it to you
right and if you don't do your training
the money goes to a charity that you
hate whatever yeah yeah yeah cool all
right
the next law is it's easy okay so make
it easy
many of our behaviors are just about
convenience you know like I so I've
started doing this thing recently where
I'll leave my phone in another room
outside of my office for until lunch
each day so I get a block of three or
four hours in the morning where it's not
around now these numbers keep going up
every year we just get more and more
addicted to our phones but the average
adult checks their phone over 150 times
a day now and if the phone is next to me
on the desk I'm like ever
else I'd look at it every three minutes
or five minutes or whatever but when I
keep it outside of my office I have this
home office all I have to do is walk up
the stairs and go to a different room
it's like 45 seconds away but I never go
do it which is fascinating to me because
it's like well I was checking my phone
every five minutes if it was next to me
so you would think I wanted to do it but
I never wanted it bad enough to walk 45
seconds upstairs and modern society has
done this weird thing where so many of
the behaviors and technologies are so
frictionless now they're so convenient
that we find ourselves doing them just
with an inkling of desire we don't
actually really want them but they're so
easy that we'll just fill space with
them and so this law of the third law is
about trying to get that to work for you
when it comes to building good habits so
reducing the number of steps between you
and the good habits and increasing the
number of steps between you and the bad
ones so you want to make it difficult
for that and one of the metaphors I like
to use is a like a garden hose so
imagine you have a hose that's like bent
in the middle and there's a little bit
of water trickling out if you want to
get more water through the hose then you
have two options the first is you could
just crank up the valve and force water
through but that increases friction and
increases tension in the the system the
other option is just to unfold the bend
and let the water flow through naturally
and that also gets more water to flow
through but it reduces tension and
reduces friction and so much of the
conversation about building better
habits and achieving peak performance is
all of the mental equivalent of cranking
up the valve you need to work harder you
need to have grit persevere hustle grind
and it's not that those qualities are
bad it's just that it increases tension
in the system and what you really want
is to create a setup where it's easy to
do the things that pay off in the long
run and you have the mentality of on the
type person it will work hard so you
wanna do the attention work yeah a more
sustainable gentle solution then you
know rise & grind versus remove these
things that are in your way every single
day that
actually are pretty easy to remove or
create distance between to make it
easier for you to do the thing that
you're trying to do you're really trying
to prime your environment to make the
default action easier and sometimes you
can do that with environment design
stuff that we talked about earlier other
times you can do it by taking actions
ahead of time that pay off in the future
so like say you're trying to build a
better sleep habit there are a variety
of one-time actions you could take today
that make it easier to get better sleep
every night after this you could test
different mattresses and see which one
leads to the best night's sleep and by
that one you could purchase blackout
curtains so that your room is dark you
could buy earmuffs or earplugs so that
you can sleep more soundly get a sleep
mask so that you you know can sleep on
the road or in hotels there are some of
those things like the chilli pad or some
of the other stuff that you know will
cool the temperature of the bed to a
more ideal rate or you can get a tent
and sleep in your backyard like I do
there you go if you could sleep outside
you could also buy there's this little
device called an outlet timer and it
costs like ten dollars on Amazon and my
friend near a all he bought one they
plugged it into his it's like an adapter
you plug it into the outlet and then you
plug the device into the timer and so he
plugged his internet router into it and
set the timer for 10 p.m. each night and
it would kill the power to the internet
router so then it's like well Netflix
doesn't work the I can't browse the web
it's time for everybody to go to bed
that's interesting and so imagine if you
just did I mean I just listed off seven
or eight things there but you know
imagine if you did five of those well
now suddenly you're in an environment
where getting better sleep as a habit is
much easier and those were all just
one-time choices that paid off for you
in the future and there's a bunch of
stuff like that depending on the habit
you know I mean Finance habits are a
good example automated savings or
automatic deposit into your 401k or
stuff like that I mean you know you want
to make this brainless so that you can
as much as possible so that you have the
energy left over to do the hard thing
when you do yeah it's weird how we've
created this world where now we have to
spend so much energy trying to
the system's too bad the system - like -
like override our DNA and impulses to
engage in these things that we think
we've created to make our lives better
and yet at the same time are creating
all these downstream problems I mean you
know the the obvious candidate the cell
phone it's like this thing is so
scientifically devised and designed to
captivate us and trigger all of those
you know impulses that we so deeply seek
that you can't blame anyone from I mean
it's like you're scrolling and you're
like I didn't even know I was scrolling
you know become so bred into us and now
we have to go way out of our way and by
all these other devices to protect
ourselves I just saw the other day I
don't know if you saw this somebody came
up with these special sunglasses that
you can put on and it makes all screens
look blank No so when you're wearing
that is actually screen yeah I think it
just makes everything look white oh man
I'm like that's really cool and it's
also insane that we have had doing about
that you know and I'm he's like or
person to spend a thousand hours like
building this company team 20 like that
this is not what they're worried about
yeah you know what I mean yeah I mean
this is just a good argument for
simplicity and minimalism you know I
think being a minimalist which I don't
know that I consider myself a staunch
minimalist but I definitely adhere to
some of the principles it's not about
having the least number of things about
having the optimal number of things and
many of the items that we choose are
surrounded by in daily life they give us
way more than the optimal number now
we're being bombarded by notifications
and text messages and all kinds of
stimuli that we're just fighting things
that we didn't have to fight before yeah
it's getting it's getting really tricky
and it's weird how this the things that
foment these bad habits like the cell
phone or you know whatever app that is
your favorite app like the amount of
money and science that's going into our
video games right like it's just all
about like keeping you wed to it for as
long as possible why is it that we can't
channel
all of that scientific genius and put
that into things that that are producing
good habits instead yeah right like all
of that you go to a Vegas casino it's
completely orchestrated to like keep you
there as long as possible right it's
it's it's an environment that is
promoting a bad habit why can't we
create environments with that amount of
intentionality and money and science
into promoting good habits yeah I mean
capitalism I think is the overriding
force here you know like it's not just
casinos airports for example there are
you know really well-paid Airport
designers that will come in to lay out a
new terminal that will specifically
decide where the walkways should be so
that you weave through the maximum
amount of stores and past the right
restaurants at the right time and you
know to spend the most money while
you're there and so anyway my point is
just that capitalism is the overriding
incentive for the people who do this
stuff and so the person who can figure
out how to make a lot of money from good
habits will have a strong reason to do
it but until people figure that out you
end up kind of we work for these
companies that do it during the day and
then as individuals we want to redesign
it for ourselves at night right like all
these YouTube is actually like my kids
are not watching YouTube right which is
you know Steve Jobs didn't let his kids
have an iPad and you know that kind of
thing right yeah I think and we need
more of that
I just read the other day as well there
was a there's somewhere I think it was I
think it might be Russia maybe I'm
remembering it wrong but someplace where
when you go to the train station or the
subway instead of having if you if you
did like 10 burpees or something yeah we
need more of that yeah that's great
I know so anyway all right ok I have one
more thing I wanna say yeah I make it
easy so the simplest way to do this is
to scale a habit down and so in the book
I talk about this thing I call the
2-minute rule and the idea is to just
take whatever habit you're trying to
build and you scale it down to the first
two minutes
and I had a I had a reader who did
something similar to this he ended up
losing over 100 pounds and one of the
ways that he did it was he went to the
gym but he wasn't allowed to stay for
longer than five minutes so state sounds
kind of crazy but for the first six
weeks he went and he showed up and did
like half an exercise and then he would
leave and go home
and to most people they hear that and
they're like well the you know it's kind
of ridiculous you're wasting your time
you're not actually getting it in shape
from that but the point is he was
mastering the art of showing up and a
habit has to be established before it
can be improved
you know like until you become the
person who shows up every day there's
nothing to optimize we're so worried
about figuring out the best diet plan or
the best business idea or the optimal
way to you know boost my bench press or
whatever it would that were we searched
for all these perfect plans but we don't
do the thing that is fundamental to all
of it which is just showing up and the
two-minute rule is one way to do that
you know you like you want to do 30
minutes a yoga well let's translate that
into take out your yoga mat or if you
want to read 30 books a year let's
translate that into read one page but
whatever the first two minutes are the
behavior scale it down master that
master the art of showing up make it as
easy as possible to get started and then
once you become that person and you're
going to the gym every day or you're
reading one page every day well now you
have options 98 90 of choices and you
can upgrade and improve from there yeah
yeah to to observations on that the
first is it goes directly to something
you talk about all the time which is
focusing on and optimizing the starting
line versus the finish line right like
we all think about the finish line we
set goals that are all about the finish
line and we overlook how important the
starting line is and the more we can
kind of we can have in the back of our
mind that destination that we're aiming
to go towards but the more we can route
ourselves in what's required to be at
that starting line then then it becomes
digestible and doable and sustainable
you don't start the race you can't
finish it yeah and people are all
worried about the outcome I mean
everybody wants to you know whatever the
outcome is run a marathon earn six
figures lose thirty pounds
it's all finish line focused but you
have to standardize before you optimize
it like you have to make it the standard
in your life before you have the chance
to optimize it and turn it into
something more yeah and I think it goes
to the second point I was going to make
it goes to this idea that I think I
think a lot of people they they really
overestimate what they can or should do
in a single day and they completely
underestimate what they're capable of in
a long term window and I'm not me I
don't mean six months I mean five years
ten years but when you when you over
when you overestimate the daily routine
it ultimately leads to burnout for most
people because it's not sustainable
right and if you can narrow that down
and and and and put it into these small
chunks like you're talking about and and
create a situation in which you have
[ __ ] u8 gradually and you create a
lifestyle that's oriented around being
able to maintain and build and optimize
on that that's where you're gonna see
the results way down the line I think
that's true and it's hard I mean this I
mentioned this in chapter one of the
book it's hard to feel that in on a
daily basis right like it I use the
metaphor if it's kind of like heating up
an ice cube you know like you you're in
a room it's cold you can see your breath
you've got this ice cube sitting on the
table in front of you it's like 25
degrees and you heat the room up in its
26 27 28 29 30 nothing's happened ice
cubes still sitting there 31 and then 32
one degree shift just like all the other
ones before and suddenly you hit this
phase transition the ice cube melts and
it's not that life is always like that
but it often feels like that you know
like people put in a little bit of work
they scale it down to this little
behavior and they think there's nothing
happening here it's like seeing an ice
cube go from 25 to 27 degrees and so
then you get you feel like well I got to
do more right I need to try harder I
need a bigger goal I need to be more
ambitious because then I'll get a bigger
result but people don't realize that
like showing up and doing something
small for three month
for six months and then complaining
about not having results it's kind of
like complaining about heating an ice
cube from twenty-five to thirty degrees
and not melting Yelp not melting it the
the work wasn't being wasted it's just
stored you know like you and that that
is a hallmark of any process that
compounds which is the most powerful
outcomes are delayed but when you're in
the thick of it when you're in the
moment it's really hard to feel that
yeah feels like nothing's happening
feels like you're wasting the time and
that's that's that's why it's so
important to understand that this is
about identity because if you're only
goal focused then you're you're not
gonna be able to stay in it because
you'll get just you'll get dissuaded or
disappointed or whatever but if this is
fundamental if you've made a decision
that this is who you are I am this
person that does this then you're not so
wed to the day-in day-out results you're
not Tabb you're not tabulating a
spreadsheet every day about whether
you're moving forward or not so this is
maybe a good time to bring up the fourth
law of behavior change because this is a
perfect example of it
so the fourth law is to make it
satisfying and what you really need is
to make it immediately satisfying and
the ultimate manifestation of that is
the reinforcement of your desired
identity if you are focused on you know
losing 30 pounds and you go run for a
month and they're like well my body
hasn't changed scales the same well not
you don't have any rewards to see but if
you're focused on becoming the type of
person who runs three times a week as
soon as you step out the door and take
two steps you're reinforcing than
identity so you can feel good in the
moment and even if it's in a small way
that's crucial for getting habits to
stick I mean this is something that I
refer to as the cardinal rule of
behavior change which is that behaviors
that are immediately rewarded get
repeated behaviors that are immediately
punished get avoid it and it's really
about the speed of how quickly you feel
satisfied or feel good you know it's
kind of like if something feels good
right after you finish it it's like a
positive emotional signal to your brain
or it's like hey this was enjoyable you
should repeat this again next time and
so in that sense positive emotions
cultivate habits and negative emotions
destroy them and you really want to find
a way to feel good to feel successful as
soon as you can
yeah that's interesting how important is
momentum in all of this because I know
that as diligent as I am about my
training and my working out I think most
people would agree if you're in the
habit of like going to the gym every day
and you've you're you're seeing results
you're part of that community and then
something happens you got a business
trip or some whatever like some some
wrench gets thrown in your plans and you
miss a day or two or maybe three days
then it becomes so hard to go back when
it was so easy to go every single day
prior to that and that's where you see
people completely fall off the wagon and
then six months goes by a year goes by
and I haven't gone once yeah so
psychologically there's something very
strange that's going on with that that
that makes that momentum something so
special and mystical that that really
needs to be like respected and cared for
because it's so powerful it's kind of
like Newton's laws applied to habits you
know objects that are in motion stay in
motion objects at rest stay at rest but
so there's a wise lesson there in what
you're you're mentioning which is first
of all all habit streaks end at some
point you know like everybody slips up
at some point and the mantra that I like
to keep in mind for that for myself as
much as anybody else is never missed
twice so if I workout the gym
Monday Wednesday Friday and I'm this on
Friday because of a business trip or
whatever then I need to put all my
energy into making sure I get in there
on Monday I don't want to miss twice in
a row it's pretty much never the first
mistake that ruins you it's like the
spiral of repeated mistakes that follows
so if you can get back on track quickly
there I think I have a line in the book
something like missing once is a mistake
missing twice as the start of a new
habit yeah because then it creates its
own negative momentum right yes right
exactly yeah it's like what's the next
right action you know and if you are if
you are identity based you'll say well
you know I'm a writer so I write this is
what I do
yeah you don't take two days off
I mean this diets are like the most
common example is what we're really
talking about here is this kind of
all-or-nothing mentality that people
have where it's like well I did the diet
for five days but then my friends wanted
to go to happy hour and I've been Jade a
little bit and so I guess I'm almost not
an age yeah I guess just too hard so I'm
just giving up and out of just like well
you know what the next time I haven't
I'm gonna sit down to eat I'm gonna make
a healthy choice exactly and maybe it's
not perfect but at least it's not Burger
King I wish I hadn't been Jade but never
missed twice so I'm gonna make sure that
next time I get back on track and eat a
healthy meal yeah so I do think momentum
plays a role there there's also a second
note about momentum and this comes back
to like video games and some of the
stuff we talked about earlier and to
that cardinal rule of behavior change as
I mentioned a lot of times the momentum
is built on the speed of the feedback
cycle so we have so far in this
conversation been talking about habits
kind of from like this larger macro
level of like a habit like going to the
gym or writing or something like that
but really biologically speaking this
process of those four stages your brain
is going through this endlessly and all
the time and in the fraction of a second
so you know take something like turning
on the light switch you walk into the
room cue the room is dark craving I
predict that if I turn the light on
it'll be better and reduce uncertainty
and I want to be able to see response I
flip on the light switch reward the room
is now lit and I can see and all of that
happens in you know a half a second and
so your brain is going through those
cycles all the time so in a sense you're
kind of always going through these
little behaviors and those little micro
cycles can build momentum as you go
through something if they're tight
enough and you have signals of progress
you're getting positive feedback and
this is what video games are incredible
at as you go through any level there are
little counters in the corner your score
is going up you're collecting more
rubies and coins every time you grab a
powerup or a weapon or something there's
a little jingle or chime even the
pitter-patter of steps as you like
advance through the scene is a signal
that you're making positive progress and
what videogames can do that it's very
hard to do in daily life is they can
keep you right on the edge so
your challenge just enough but still
making progress you know like if you are
really killing it on a certain level
they start to take away some of those
power-ups and give you more difficult
challenges to face if you're struggling
they'll give you more coins and rubies
and you know like help you along a
little bit and so they are always making
sure that you're making just enough
progress through the level while still
being challenged enough to be engaged
and that is like uh I mean this has been
shown with with research variable
rewards and keeping you cut on this
razor's edge of difficulty is one of the
peak ways to maintain motivation and
momentum and want to stay engaged with a
habit and technology makes it easier for
us to do that which is one reason those
behaviors and games are so addictive
yeah I mean it's ingenious it's just
being channeled for a less than
productive you know outcome for a human
animal right like it just makes me go
back to that point of like why can't we
take all of that and create a healthy
eating or fitness app or or an or or an
app that would work within the structure
of a professional organization to
enhance productivity so I think we
create I think it's possible but I think
that it probably won't take the form
that people would expect in many cases
the most effective behavior change apps
actually change behavior through like a
trapdoor and this is just me theorizing
right now I don't have any proof of this
but like if I think about what is the
most effective exercise app that's been
created in the last decade well it's
probably not actually an exercise app
it's probably something like Pokemon go
because that got people that got
millions of people to walk five or ten
miles a day but it wasn't an exercise
app at all and I think that there's
something may be there for people who do
have good intentions who want to change
the world in a positive way and are
really serious about changing behavior
think about what those trap doors are
what are things that actually motivate
people saving money making more money
winning the praise and approval and
respect to their friends earning a
higher score on the leaderboard and if
you can figure out how to have a
secondary healthy behavior happening as
they do that that might actually be
something that could really
can get millions of people to do
something different yeah we explained
that idea of the secondary healthy habit
so pokemons go the real thing that
people are trying to do is collect these
pokemons and get a higher score in
whatever but the secondary habit is to
do that you have to go walk around the
right and see where they're hidden
throughout the park and all that type of
stuff right and so it's not none of the
people playing that thing I'm gonna walk
five miles today yeah they just think I
need to go find with this yeah and it
goes back to your your you know original
law which is if you know how creating a
system that promotes the healthy
behavior without people even necessarily
being consciously aware of it right
that's ultimately how you move the
needle it happens all the time you know
I mean we've talked about multiple
negative or maybe less healthy examples
with cell phones and things like that
where we we aren't really thinking about
like oh I want to sit on my couch and
browse Instagram for three hours like
nobody's waking up thinking that they're
just thinking oh I got more likes and
now you know one of my friends up too
and blah blah blah so that's kind of a
secondary action that comes from that
and this is just twisting it or flipping
it on its head a little bit and think
about how we can have secondary actions
that are healthier yeah all right so
what's the difference between focusing
on creating a good habit versus focusing
on eradicating or overcoming a bad habit
like where should the focus and
intention go yeah that's a great
question I haven't been asked that
before but I think actually there's
there's some important like keys so I'll
let me start with a bad habit I think
the most effective place to focus on
breaking a bad habit is the first and
the third stage of my four-step model so
the first stage is making it invisible
sounds like reducing exposure so you
know I talked about like hiding the
television for example or really common
example people here like make sure you
don't have any sweets in the house
processed food right or pantry so in
many cases again not for true addictions
but for just these bad habits that we
have we just do them because they're
around us so it's like well if you want
to spend less my
Electronics don't follow all the tech
review blogs you know you're constantly
being prompted to buy something or if
you want to lose weight don't follow a
bunch of food bloggers on Instagram you
know you're like continually have to
overcome that stimuli so the more that
you can cut out that stimuli and reduce
exposure to the negative cues
maybe that bad habit loop just never get
started and so that's one effective way
I'd skip over the second stage because
our interpretation of cues the
prediction that we have it happens so
fast it happens lightning-fast as soon
as you see that food blog on Instagram
you immediately think about your mouth
watering and wanting to eat something
and being able to like shortcut that and
circumvent that it's possible the one of
the things that you have to do is like
kind of reframe your mindset and make
that thing that previously meant
something mean something else which you
can do but it's just it's hard sorry
yeah this is operating on the
unconscious mind right so you can rewire
your neurology over time with new habits
that create those new neural pathways
but that's a steeper mountain to climb
and it takes a long time you know so if
you join a you know if you if you
previously ate pork but then you join a
religion that doesn't allow you to eat
pork and you start to belong to that
group and you develop friends there and
stuff well then yeah maybe at some point
you'll see pork is very unattractive so
you've like reframed how you interpret
that Q but it's it might take a while to
do that you need to actually build the
friendships and have a strong reason to
stick with you know with that new belief
system so anyway I'm gonna skip over the
second stage cuz it's I think it's more
difficult for a bad habit and then the
other area where I think you can focus
is the third step which is make it
difficult in the case of breaking a bad
habit and if you can increase the
friction enough you won't follow through
so one of the examples I like to give
Victor Hugo famous writer and author he
he signed this book deal to write the
Hunchback of Notre Dom and he just kind
of like goofed off for a year he had
friends over and had a bunch of parties
he went and traveled he went out to
restaurants didn't really do a whole lot
and the publishers got all annoyed with
them and they set this all to meet him
and they were like listen you need to
get this book down
six months we're going to cancel a deal
so he had his assistant come into his
his room and took all of his clothes out
of his closet and put him in a chest and
they locked him up and the only thing
that he was left with was like this
large shawl this like robe and so he
didn't have any clothes that were
suitable for having friends over or for
hosting parties we couldn't travel
outside of the house he effectively put
himself on house arrest and so my point
there was he made it difficult to
procrastinate
he made it difficult to do the behavior
he didn't want to do and it ended up
working he got the book done like two
weeks early he wrote in like five 1/2
months and then he knows now we have the
Hunchback of Notre Dom yeah I mean it
goes back to to being intentional about
your environment I heard a similar story
about Jonathan Franzen I think it was
when he was writing freedom maybe but he
rented like a crappy like the the most
unappealing office like little like like
almost like a hotel room in a terrible
building like Santa Cruz with like no
view or any and all it was was like like
a horrible table and a really
uncomfortable chair and it was like
nothing on the walls nothing you know
just to go no distractions just right
Maya Angelou does something similar I
think she for many of her book she rents
a hotel room and she leaves her house
drives there and writes yes nothing else
a lot of writers in Hollywood do that
yeah they go to fancy hotels and order
lots of room service right yeah I mean
that makes sense so so back to this idea
of focusing on building good habits
versus so that's where I think you
should focus for bad habits
for good habits I really think all four
are effective the stuff that we talked
about earlier with making it attractive
and joining a new tribe I think that's
the most difficult of the four because
you're asking someone to change their
friend group or to find new friends at
least you don't I don't think you have
to like abandon the people that are in
your currently in your life if you want
to change your habits but it's just
easier to adopt a new habit if you have
some friends that are also doing that
new thing is there any research on the
difference between an in-person peer
group like joining a running
or whatever versus like being on a
Facebook group where like you're
somewhere where that community doesn't
exist right but you have this peer group
that's available to you through the
laptop yeah it's a good question I have
not seen Studies on it it's possible
something has been done I just haven't
seen it but I think that having a group
like you know you're a member of a
community on reddit or a Facebook group
or something like that it's probably
better than not having it if nothing
else you're kind of like ceding those
ideas in your brain that maybe you
wouldn't be getting from your your
physical environment but what I'm really
interested to see and who knows when
this will happen maybe will be 10 years
maybe will be a hundred but some kind of
augmented reality or virtual reality
solution I was just talking today I was
like calming I was just talking to
someone the other day about this she has
this this idea of this company where
it's a virtual reality and you
effectively use it for like self
improvement or behavior change so you
just throw the goggles on and now you're
suddenly in a room with ten other people
who are trying to build the same habit
the you are so it's like a Facebook
group except it feels like you're in
person right everybody knows that being
in a Facebook group doesn't feel like
what it feels like to go to your local
gym yeah but what if suddenly it did if
it did have more of that feel and it
felt almost real then I don't know I'd
be interested to know like you could
live anywhere you live in the middle of
the woods and suddenly have access to
what feels like an in-person group and
you get the accountability from that
yeah well I think there's no way that's
not happening yeah agreed
I mean there'll be a lot of crazy
not-so-good stuff comes with that you
know technology but I can see all kind
of benefits with that kind of thing yeah
what about this idea of the way in which
the adoption of good habits begin to
crowd out the bad habits so that was
gonna be one of the next things I want
to add to the the good habits piece
there are two two things that's one of
them in many cases building a good habit
it's kind of like you know how plants
can like crowd another out and so as as
the good habit is formed it kind of
naturally crowds out the bad one so
let's say for example that you both want
to get in shape and workout more and you
wish you watch less TV or something well
if you usually watch TV for three hours
when you get home from work
each day and you just get home from work
and changing your workout clothes and go
to the gym instead and you just focus on
the habit of going to the gym you don't
even really need to think about the
television one it just doesn't happen
automatically because you're at the gym
and you're working out during that time
so there are lots of times when stuff
like that will occur where the creation
of a good habit will just naturally
crowd out a bad one and another way to
think about this is behaviors often come
in bundles like they they're related to
each other right like you you go to the
bathroom and then you wash your hands
and then after you wash your hands you
dry your hands and drying your hands
reminds you that you need to throw the
laundry in and then you think about oh
we're out of detergents and they need to
go to the store and you know like
they're all kind of connected and in
many cases both bad habits and good
habits can kind of come in these bundles
and so if you if you start to do
something else that like pulls on one
thread in the bundle then the whole
stack of bad habits like yeah it's not a
binary one-to-one equation if you if you
start going to the gym and you start to
see results then you're gonna be more
interested in eating healthy and then
you're gonna be more interested in
getting a good night's sleep and then
hey what's this meditation thing and
before you know it like you know your
life is completely different that's why
I think exercise is like one of my keys
don't have it's one of the crucial ones
for me because I I have like this
post-workout high where I can focus for
like an hour and get some good work done
or think clearly I tend to eat better
naturally just which is weird right you
would think oh you work out so then you
could waste it but I don't want to waste
it that's like kind of feeling
I sleep better at night because I'm
tired which means I wake up in the
morning and I have better energy and at
no point was I trying to build better
sleep habits or energy habits or focus
habits or nutrition habits it all just
kind of came as this natural side effect
and exercise is a common one I mean it's
mine but it's also common to many people
what are the other ones
well there's so like visualization is
one that you hear from a lot of
performers like comedians or something
they'll go through the same
visualization routine or athletes before
they step onto stage or step out to
perform a daily walk is a really common
one amongst creatives there's a book
called daily rituals by Maison carrée
where he talks about the rituals of a
bunch of scientists and composers and
writers
and probably like 75 percent of it was
alcohol and drugs and then the ones that
are clean at daily walk is like ones
that are still producing at a high level
20 years later you know have you heard
of what David Sedaris does no what does
he do it's insane
he I mean he's bananas in the best way
but he has some very weird behavioral
quirks and I think this must be driven
by some kind of bizarre OCD but he lives
like in the English countryside
yeah and for some reason he just became
obsessed with the amount of like litter
that was everywhere so he would he start
it out like and this goes back to like
creatives taking a walk like he'd go out
and any pick up litter and now he he
walks every day for like eight hours
picking up litter all over the place
every single day like it's some weird
compulsion where he just feels and when
he travels and he goes out of town like
he does it in whatever like not for like
an hour like eight hours so I was like
well there's something very unhealthy
about that but at the same time I I was
left wondering like how does that inform
his creative process like perhaps this
is by giving him some kind of steady low
state activity it allows him to free
associate in a certain way that perhaps
contributes to the incredible writing
that he does I don't know I don't know
the science behind that but I have had
similar thoughts to the one you just add
which is maybe like going for a walk
kind of gives your yeah the steady state
or like maybe it even gives your
non-conscious something to do and you
somehow like get out of your own way a
little bit because you're busy doing
that stuff and like him making one foot
move in front of the other and that
opens up the floodgates for an
interesting idea to hit you right but
okay so I didn't know that that was
where you're going with the Sedaris
thing but I had heard that at some point
that he has this and I heard a great
story which is that he so he goes around
picking up his garbage for like eight or
nine hours and he's done it so much that
he got this award from the Queen of
England yeah
picking it up and he thought that he was
gonna have like a private audience with
the Queen for it and so he goes to
Buckingham Palace and it turns out
they're like four thousand other people
that were being honored for their civic
work as well and anyway he's just
talking about like how how he thought he
was gonna get to spend like an hour with
the Queen and instead she like shook his
hand for half a second took a picture in
the mail all right anyway
where were we we were talking about okay
so there was no and the oh well okay let
me wrap up the so visualization going
for a walk exercise and then meditation
is the common Keystone habit that people
will talk about especially you know CEOs
or whatever they get their ten minutes
of meditation in or 20 minutes and they
feel like the rest of the day kind of
falls in line and then another weird one
that I've heard about from some of my
readers is budgeting or specifically
paying off debt when people pay their
debt off it starts to ripple into other
areas that like start exercising and
suddenly like I um you know this was
even part of it but it it seems to know
it's such a heavy you know thing to kind
of just care it like a dull low-grade
you know burden there's ways on you
without you even really being
consciously aware of it and when you're
carrying something like that around or
you're under undue financial duress it's
hard to be creative it's hard to be your
best self because it's just this thing
it's weighing on you all the time hmm so
so those are some of the keys don't
habits
the only other point I was gonna make
about crowding out bad habits and
focusing on good ones is that figuring
out ways to feel successful in the
moment that immediate satisfaction
that's a really strong place to focus
for building good habits there are some
examples products a really good example
those businesses are good at this so
like chewing gum for many years chewing
gum has been around for a long time but
for most of the time it was like this
bland resin it was chewy but it wasn't
tasty and then Wrigley came along in the
late 1800s and they added juicy fruit
and spearmint and double mint and black
first time what if it didn't have taste
I don't know the burbs board I don't
know
but they anyway so they it was finally
tasty right away and all sudden chewing
them takes office this worldwide haven't
Wrigley becomes the the most popular
chewing gum company in the world and in
modern society there are still tons of
examples of stuff like this recently a
couple years ago BMW added this system
to one of their cars where it would pump
fake engine growl noise through the
speakers so whenever you stepped on the
gas it would like be more satisfying to
read the engine about we're such dumbass
unbelievable Ford is doing something
similar they have like a this little
valve system where usually it's blocked
and the car is soundproofed but if you
really slam on the gas the valve will
open up and will let the engine noise in
and you feeling this guttural where
aliens should just come and take us over
but the the point here and how to apply
it to good habits is that if you have
some kind of immediate feedback via
media positive feedback and feel good in
the moment then you have a reason to
repeat it
and we already talked about identity
being one aspect of that like as soon as
you go to the gym you can feel like
you're the type person who doesn't miss
workouts or whatever and that's one
little bit of satisfaction habit
tracking I don't think you always need
to track or measure your habits but for
certain areas for the ones that are
important to you that can be an
effective way to do this too you know
like if you the most simple form is just
put like an X on the calendar each time
you do a workout or whatever well if you
do that every Monday Wednesday and
Friday as soon as you finish the workout
it feels good to record that I mean I
write down like all the sets and reps
that I do it feels good to close the
book and have another workout finished
and of course there's a million apps now
that do that great thing from Strava to
the aura ring and everything in between
the point though the central point is
just finding small ways to feel
satisfied them yeah
gives you a reason to repeat the good
habit in the future I like this idea of
batching you use this example of one way
to kind of confront and overcome a bad
habit is to combine it with a good habit
so there's the example of the woman who
who you know wanted to watch Hunger
Games but then she's like she's only
allowed to watch it if she's doing it
while she's at the gym so like creating
the the reward mechanism for the
quote-unquote like you know less than
stellar behavior has to be built into or
part and parcel of doing something that
is part of the healthy habit that you're
trying to bring into your life yeah so
this is called temptation bundling and
the the researcher Katie milkman who's
at the Wharton School at University of
Pennsylvania she's the one who actually
had she'd ran the study but she also had
that personal example if she liked The
Hunger Games but she knew she need to
work out more so she was only allowed to
read the book at the gym but it's a
larger application of what's called pre
max principle which is the psychological
principle that behaviors that are more
likely to be performed will reinforce
behaviors that are less likely to be
performed if you can kind of combine
them together and my favorite example of
this there's this engineering student in
Ireland and he rigged up his stationary
bike at home to his computer so that
Netflix would only turn on when he was
pedaling right and if you stop pedaling
the Netflix app once it goes back to
that same thing we've created all these
you know now we have so many things that
we have to do to overcome the links that
we'll go to you know but but in that
case Netflix was the more attractive or
more satisfying behavior and so who's
that to incentivize himself to get on
the site again the biking and cycle and
it's that delicate balance like if if
what he had to do to watch Netflix was
too daunting then he just wouldn't watch
Netflix hmm right see if it has to be in
that like sweet spot where it's
uncomfortable but okay I'll do it
this is kind of a larger overriding
theme of our conversation so far and
something that's probably important to
keep in mind which is you need to be
willing to experiment you know like
everybody's running their race in life
separately and so you have to you can
use science to inform your strategy and
that's a good way it's a good way to
have educated guesses and kind of like
nudge you in the right direction but you
have to be willing to perform these n of
one experiments
to see you know like what is a habit
that's right on that razor's edge that's
just motivating enough that I'll go
ahead and do it but not so hard than
like odd just screw it entirely yeah and
only you can know that for yourself and
I think sometimes that's frustrating for
people because they just want to be
handed like a book and be like hey
here's the answer and as best I could I
tried to write that book four habits but
the truth is you need to you need to be
willing to experiment and run these kind
of personal journeys to figure out what
does work for you yeah there's no
question about that all right let's talk
about goals you have some interesting
thoughts on goals the traditional
conventional wisdom being like hey if
you want to score you got to set a goal
if you want to know where you're going
set a goal no goal is too big don't sell
yourself short and what's the problem
with goals
okay so first before I come off as
someone who completely hates goals I I
think goals are useful I think they're
useful for setting a sense of direction
but once you know what direction you're
moving in then I think it's best to put
the goal on the shelf and focus on the
system or focus on the process in the
habits and the this was first an idea
that was kind of like thrown out to me
or I saw this kind of dichotomy between
systems and goals by Scott Adams who
wrote the the Dilbert comic and I think
he's a little more adamant about it than
I am I think he says like goals are for
losers and stuff like that which I don't
think it is entirely true but there is
there are a couple interesting problems
with goals so one problem is the winners
and losers in any particular domain
often have the same goals so every
Olympian wants to win the gold medal
every candidate who applies for a job
wants to get the job so if they all have
the same goal by definition the goal
cannot be the thing that makes the
difference between the people who get it
and those who don't but you're not gonna
win the gold medal if you're if you
don't have a goal to win the gold medal
so I think we could say that goals are
necessary but not sufficient and that's
why I think they're useful they're
useful for setting a sense of direction
you know like every nick saban and
Alabama show up they know from day one
the goal is to win the national title
and this is one of the beautiful things
about sports is that it's so
I can white like that is so clear-cut
that okay we all know what the goal is
and now we can just say let's not talk
about the national title what practice
everyday let's just focus on the process
in the system but there isn't really a
national championship of tech startups
or of you know of a lot of other things
in life and so for that it's like a
little a little Messier because people
often need those milestones to know that
they're still pointed in the right
direction so I think it's good for that
but I think that generally speaking
we've become a very goal and outcome
obsessed Society and part of that is
because that's what the news shows us
every day you know like you're never
gonna see a news story that is like
woman eats salad and chicken for lunch
today it's only on story act if she
loses a story in the onion yeah but
probably from that before you know but
it's only after the outcome has occurred
that it becomes a story and social media
has just like magnified this even more
because all we do is just see people's
outcomes and results and highlights all
day long I think because we are
inundated with results and goals we
think having a big goal having the
result having the outcome is what we
should focus on and so we spend 90% of
our time thinking about obsessing over
planning these goals and only 10% of our
time actually worrying about the process
and it should probably be reversed
well I think what goals do well is they
create clarity of purpose right so I yes
Sports is a very black-and-white
template where goals make sense startup
culture well you know what is the goal
is it you know it's it's more unclear
but I think every successful startup or
startup entrepreneur has some kind of
true north and that may not be
financially rooted it may be in changing
the world or whatever it may be but
there needs to be a directional
guideposts so that the team or the
individual can cohere around a
trajectory mm-hm
so I think it makes sense in that regard
because it's a reminder of like where
you're going
and why but I agree with you that once
you set the goal then it becomes about
systems like you should sort of forget
about it and be and and and focus all of
your attention on like what is the next
thing that you're doing right rather
than like talking about this thing that
you know may not happen for 10 years or
20 years I mean you know it may just of
the Olympic gold goal but you know the
person who wins the gold medal probably
set that goal when they were 8 years old
right so it's been this true North
that's kind of gently guiding them in a
certain direction for a very long time
yeah I mean just add a couple things of
that so let's say that you are that tech
startup and you have some clear goals
about what you want the culture to be or
the the the direction of the company to
be where people should focus each day
the interesting thing is that the goals
can be useful for that clarity but
really they don't determine much in the
long run your true culture as a company
is not the goals that you put on paper
or the mission statement that you put on
the wall your true cultures the shared
habits of the team if it's not a habit
among the organization it's not actually
part of your culture it's just something
you did one time in like a thought
building exercise and I think that that
kind of puts goals in their proper place
which is yes it's very useful for us all
to know what direction we're trying to
row in but unless we're actually rowing
unless we're actually doing the the
habits then it's not really part of this
and so that's one thing the second thing
is that achieving a goal only changes
your life for the moment
yeah it's temporal right whereas
identity has a permanence to it there's
a there's an example I use with this for
cleaning your room you know like you get
really motivated you got a messy room
and so your goal becomes to have a clean
room so you clean it up but you have a
clean room for the moment but if you
don't change like the sloppy messy
packrat habits that led to a messy room
in the first place you turn around two
weeks or a month later and you have a
messy room again and so we think that
the thing that needs to change is the
result but actually what we really need
to change is the process behind the
results we like treat a symptom without
treating the cause right well in your
example
you're actually treating this symptom
rather than the root cause it's like
taking a blood blood pressure medication
without changing your lifestyle habits
right right but I think this is really
common when people set goals because
they think only about the outcome they
think about the clean room they think
about the million dollar bank account
they think about the fit six-pack abs
but what they don't think about is what
kind of lifestyle do you need to live to
get that thing and unless you actually
want the whole lifestyle that's
associated with that result it doesn't
make a whole lot of sense to make it
your goal you know but it becomes very
easy to get wrapped up in that because
all we ever see is the outcome rather
than the process yeah you also have this
interesting idea about the the sort of
peril of good habits and how that can
kind of create a comfort zone for people
so I think that and we mentioned this
early on the habits of the foundation of
her I think that habits of the
foundation for mastery you know so
LeBron or whatever like all those
examples of automating as much as you
can of the the process but there is a
downside to building good habits and
that is that at first you become aware
of something that you want to change
then you like deliberately practice it
for a while you put effort in and as you
do that you develop fluency and skill
and ability and what was previously
difficult becomes easy and you have it
relies it but once it's a habit
the downside is you stop paying
attention as much when you can do
something pretty good on autopilot you
stop thinking about how to do it better
and there's actually an interesting
study that's been done on surgeons that
shows that early on in their career they
go through residency they increase
fluency and skill they start practicing
surgery maybe for a few years and then
actually their skills get to a peak and
then once they've done it for a while
and they're pretty good at it it's not
that they drop off a cliff but there's a
slight decline in performance because
they can do so many of the steps on
autopilot they stop thinking about did I
make a little error there to make a
mistake to I overlook one step yeah
there's a rigidity you become less
teachable yeah and you become less
cognizant of where you might be slipping
by I know and so one of my favorite
examples of this I mean this is one of
the values of having a coach is that
coaches keep you aware of your mistake
when you are no longer Atul Gawande
who's a fantastic writer in his own
right and as a surgeon he got us
everything
oh it's insane is his straight I'm
genius thank God ya know he's fantastic
I also think complications was his best
book and it doesn't get nearly as much
press as I think it should but he anyway
he hired another surgeon who had
recently retired to review the tape of
his surgery and tell him like where he
was going wrong and what he was you know
what he could improve on and I love that
because surgeons never get coaches right
that's not a thing in that industry but
you don't have to be an athlete to have
a coach like find a mentor or someone
who recently retired someone who's 10
years ahead of where you're at and have
them critique what you're up to and that
is a really instructive and powerful way
to kind of overcome or at least become
aware of some of your habits that the
downside of some of your habits that
maybe you're overlooking yeah or or
perhaps develop habits around making
sure that you're always tiptoeing
outside your comfort zone or habits that
encourage you to to always have people
around you that will give you that
critical feedback and push you nudge you
just a little bit yeah yeah from that
that comfortable place I mean that so
that that maybe is what I'm talking
about here as habits are formed they
become a comfortable place and usually
growth is on the perimeter of that
rather than in the middle and so you
need some reason or some way to stay on
the perimeter of your abilities and keep
stretching rather than staying
comfortable where do you most people go
wrong with all this I think probably the
biggest thing is making a habit too big
so we talked a little bit about the
two-minute rule and that idea of scaling
and have it down to just the first two
minutes of optimizing for the starting
line rather than finish line that's a
huge one the second one would be the
all-or-nothing mentality where we talked
about like never missed twice you know
make sure that I you know like get back
on track as quickly as possible rather
than acting like well if I can't run
three days a week and why bother at all
you know like doing it once it's fine
so that's another huge issue and then in
the long run the two things that I think
are most crucial are identity adopting
that
type of identity and casting votes for
the person you want to become even if
it's in a really small way so you start
to see yourself and build up evidence of
being that person and then the second
one is social environment you know like
in the long run it's really hard to
stick to a habit if it goes against the
grain of the people that are around you
whereas if you get praised and respected
for it people stick to things even if
they don't have a factual basis for them
even if they don't have a good reason
because the the social component and the
belonging is so strong yeah the identity
one is huge you know I I think really a
huge problem is that people are not
adequately in touch enough with
themselves and their impulses who they
are and where they want to be like
they're not connected to their interior
landscape to the extent that their
choice of identity or goal is
necessarily reliable because most people
are not engaged in that internal process
of trying to really understand what
makes them tick and and who they want to
be and what I see is a lot of people
chasing the wrong thing and they may be
very good at executing on that goal or
that habit that takes them there only to
later discover that that whole pursuit
was you know really not what they should
have been doing in the first place
there's a quite a quote right always
like I hope everybody gets everything
they ever wanted and realizes that
wasn't what they actually needed yes or
I can't remember who it was it said this
like you know you spend your whole life
climbing this ladder only to realize
it's leaning against the wrong wall
right which becomes a much broader
discussion about you know psychology I
suppose in general but all right well we
got a we got a start to close this thing
down but um why don't we if you could
leave us with a couple things that
people can take away to perhaps you know
kind of tweak how they look at and think
about the habits that they're trying to
change in their own lives and some
simple steps to get them started
and taking making better decisions sure
so I'll give you one mindset shift and
one practical application so the mindset
shift and this kind of lies beneath the
entire conversation we had today is to
just try to find a way to get 1% better
each day it doesn't need to be something
radical it doesn't need to be something
huge but habits are easy to overlook
both good and bad on any given day
because they don't seem like very much
the difference between studying Spanish
for an hour tonight and not studying at
all seems like nothing is like why I
still didn't learn the language and the
difference between eating a salad versus
eating a burger and fries
seems like nothing because your body
looks the same in the mirror and the
scale is the same at the end of the
night it's only once your habits have
compounded over two or five or ten years
that the full impact of those 1% choices
one percent better or one percent worse
becomes fully apparent and if you can
understand that concept and internalize
it then you can start to see the
importance in your daily actions and in
your daily habits and why those are so
critical so that's the first thing is
just try to find a way to get 1% better
and the second thing just a practical
application I would encourage you to try
to apply the 2 minute rule think about
whatever habit it is that you're trying
to build and scale it down to just the
first two minutes of the behavior what
is the thing that you can do that can
initiate it don't think about it as like
the overall habit think about it like a
gateway habit or an entrance ramp to a
highway
how can you automate the beginning of
the behavior and this is this is maybe
an important distinction about habits a
lot of the time we talk about habits as
we use the phrase habit for things that
aren't actually habits like we'll say
something like I want to build the habit
of writing every day technically we
define this at the very beginning of
this episode a habit is a behavior that
can be performed more or less
automatically and it's on autopilot
writing is about the most effortful
concentrated thing that you can do right
like you're gonna be thinking carefully
you're not gonna be on autopilot so the
habit part of that would be I sit in a
chair at a desk with a pad of paper in
front of me or a laptop the habit is the
first two minutes right
how can you automate the ritual of
getting started and then let the
consequence and the the effortful
concentrating work follow naturally same
way with you know the example I gave
about my reader the habit was showing up
at the gym you know or for running a lot
of people a lot of people have heard
stuff like this before
like hey take small steps but even when
you know you should start small it's
still really easy to start too big
people are like alright I want to build
the habit of running so I guess I know I
should start small so I only run for 15
minutes but even that's like way bigger
than what I'm talking about
scale it down just the first two minutes
automate the ritual of getting started
putting on your running shoes stepping
out the door locking the door and if you
can automate that and make that a habit
you do a day in and day out and you're
the type of person who always gets their
running shoes own steps out the door
there gonna be a lot of days where you
yeah it's great advice it's great advice
alright James clear I think we did it
this is awesome man thanks rich I
appreciate it feel good yeah I feel
great
anything else you want to say do we say
it all we could keep going we could
there's a there's a lot in the book that
we didn't get to cover which might seem
incredible given how much we covered
here but book is very thorough oh thank
you yeah yeah I'm glad you enjoyed it I
there's that there are some sections
that I find really interesting like
there I have a section on genes and
habits and like choosing oh yeah we
talked about like genetic factors yeah
we can talk about let's do it all right
there's a there's like a running joke
out on the internet but I always say
like alright we're wrapping this up and
then I go two hours later alright so
here's my thought on genes in many cases
the genes that are well we often don't
like to talk about genes in biology
because it seems like a fixed
characteristic right bio is saying that
like oh your genetics had seen nobody
likes to think like oh what's out of my
control why bother but the truth is the
usefulness or the applicability of your
genes is highly dependent on context so
being seven feet tall is an incredible
advantage if you're trying to play
basketball and it's an incredible
disadvantage if you're trying to be a
gymnast and just as that is very obvious
with physical traits it's becoming
increasingly true as we develop more
understanding of the link between genes
and psychological traits
your personality and so for certain
personalities certain habits or certain
environments might be predisposed to
being really successful enjoyable or not
the I think there's a lot to improve in
this area I think there's like a lot for
us still to learn but it's so many ways
we might just be in the infancy of
understanding this but one of the best
measures or most robust measures of
personality is the big five in this kind
of like mapping personality traits on to
five different spectrums the most common
one that people know is introversion and
extraversion but there are other ones as
well agreeableness conscientiousness and
so on and each of these five traits has
been linked to some kind of genetic
underpinning some type of DNA and so one
of my favorite studies on this
researchers took babies that were in the
nursery and they played a harsh noise on
one side of the nursery and some of the
babies turn toward the noise and some of
them turned away and as they track those
children as they grew up throughout life
they found the ones that turned toward
the noise were more likely to grow up to
be extroverts and the ones that turned
away were more likely to grow up to be
introvert yeah the extroverts are in the
mosh pit are at home watching Netflix so
again I think there's still a lot to
learn
but there's definitely something going
on here people for example who have
higher levels of agreeableness tend to
have higher natural levels of oxytocin
as well and so you can imagine how
someone who is high in agreeableness
might be more likely or it might be
easier for them to build a habit of
writing thank-you notes or of organizing
social events where people can be warm
and hang out and kind and consider it
and so on they're that kind of
personality and so there may be
predisposed to that kind of habit where
gets interesting is if you can
understand yourself
at a more I guess I'll even call a
genetic level then maybe you can start
to design habits that fit you better or
design an environment that fits you
better so one of the examples I gave in
the book and again I'm just kind of I'm
still like toying with some of these
ideas is for people who are low in
conscientiousness which is one of those
five traits that means that they're less
likely to be orderly or less likely to
be or
so if someone is like that if they're
predisposed to be that kind of person
it might really help them to be in an
environment to have an environment
designed where things are already
orderly or primed or set up because
they're going to be less likely to be
the type of person that would just
remember to do it or to make a to-do
list to do it and so on and so maybe if
you knew oh I'm low in conscientiousness
you should shift more of your energy and
attention to environment design yeah
yeah that's that's super interesting I
mean in the book you talk about you know
Michael Phelps who has a physique that's
perfectly suited to him swimming very
fast and then you have this jicama guru
yeah a long-distance runner who they
have the same inseam but you know the
proportionality of their bodies are
completely different and he's
well-suited in a long-distance running
they could not swap places and the point
being that from afar the casual observer
will say well of course he's good at
swimming like look at his body I can't
do that but the greater point that
you're trying to make is if we can
develop self-awareness around you know
what suits us best in our
predispositions and gravitate towards
those environments and those
opportunities then we're putting
ourselves in a position where the
expression of our genetic makeup can
advance us and fuel us and and you know
put us in the position that is you know
best for us right I don't know if this
is going to end up being possible it's
but it's possible that there may be a
few key traits like the if for measuring
intelligence is a hot topic and
difficult to do because there are many
different types of intelligence but if
for example being having winning the
genetic lottery and intelligence happens
to be like a cheat code and it helps you
succeed in any area of life then maybe
maybe this what I'm about to say isn't
as accessible but what I think could be
possible and is a really inspiring
notion to me is if we could
appropriately map your personality and
genes then maybe we could better suit
people to environments where they could
be excellent and that would be a
wonderful thing for everyone to be able
to feel and experience what it's like to
be excellent at something what it's like
to be world-class or to succeed and
many ways it's just a matching problem
you know like what if Michael Phelps
grew up in a family that was all runners
and had never swam and he never got
exposed to that well there probably is a
guy you know yeah ocular brown right now
who has a physique that's even better
suited for the 200 butterfly and has
never been in a swimming pool right it's
like we don't know because we're ping
pong balls bouncing around and we kind
of you know find our own water level
eventually some of us do but it leaves
you wondering well how many people
aren't finding that you know perfect
outlet where the world you know you talk
about luck you've written about like
luck and and you know you use Bill Gates
an example like there's a lot of luck
involved he was born in America and he
was in this you know the timing was
right everything was perfect for him to
be the person that he ultimately becomes
about how many people out there have
that potential where the world doesn't
converge in a way that allows them to
express whatever gift is innate within
them and my hope is that there are
enough niches throughout the world that
there are enough ways for people to fit
in and find their their thing where they
can be excellent where they're like
perfectly suited for that and it's just
this matching problem that we don't
right now it really is like ping pong
balls is just luck
is I mean it's it's luck that Michael
Phelps grew up in the right in the right
environment the right family the right
situation for that and that doesn't
discount any of the hard work that he
did you know I mean he worked he worked
his butt off but he was in the he
happened to also have been matched with
the right thing at the beginning
including like the perfect amount of
psychological trauma to fuel the
competitive nature within him like there
it's all of it right and I think we're
headed towards a future where AI and
genetic testing are going to be able to
answer some of these questions for
people and that's fraught with all kinds
of other perils but there is something
interesting about that Israel in the
meantime you kind of leave people with
this question which is what are you well
suited to suffer for right something
like that paraphrasing I think it which
is a way of kind of prompting that self
inquiry a lot of people try to figure
out like yes so in that chapter after a
set of questions that you can go through
to try to figure it out for your
what are you most appropriately matched
for what what environment would suit you
and one of the key questions I think is
where's an area where you can handle the
pain of the work better than the people
around you the area where you are more
well equipped to suffer is the work that
you were made to do which is an
interesting way to think about it right
like most people think about oh well
where is it just easy where do I succeed
but every area requires hard work and
effort to achieve some level of success
so the question is not where is it easy
the question is where can I handle the
pain mm-hmm yeah it's a total it's a
different lens through which to look at
it but I think that that I think that's
it I think that's right you know for
some people for some for whatever reason
people who grow up and you know become
great writers they writing is suffering
but they can handle it for some reason
Navy SEALs like it's not easy to be one
but the guys who can make it somehow
they can handle the suffering of it yeah
they're and they're well suited and and
prepared and willing to undergo that for
some reason and I think I used that line
something similar to that at the end of
that chapter which is at the peak of any
field what you're going to find are
people who are both well suited and well
trained it's not just one or the other
they have the environment matching and
they have the hard work and the effort
and the perseverance right habits are
the compound interest of
self-improvement I love it that's one of
my favorite lines I think it
encapsulates the core idea right that
like if you're willing to build those
small behaviors and layer 1%
improvements on top of each other they
will compound and multiply the same way
that money multiplies through compound
interests the effects of your habits
multiplies you repeat them over time and
that can be true for you or against you
and that's why it's crucial to
understand how habits work so that you
can you know make sure that they're
they're multiplying in your favor
rather than to your detriment you heard
it here people right from the source I
love it man thank you so much I really
appreciate your wisdom the book is
fantastic I think it's going to help a
lot of people so I'm excited for you are
you going out on a big book tour you're
going to be around where people can come
and hear you talk and stuff like that
yeah thank you I'm so grateful and
pleased to hear that you enjoyed it so
thanks for that
and we probably will do a book tour at
some point I'll definitely be in New
York for the launch on October 16th but
in the meantime people can find the book
and learn more about it at atomic habit
huh right and James clear calm at James
clear pretty much everywhere on the
Internet
yeah yeah pretty much just James clear
calm is the place to go check out some
of my articles I've got it organized by
category so if you want to just bounce
around so it would interest you and then
there are links to social media and all
that others you have this newsletter
with like 8 zillion people who subscribe
and read your stuff right yeah that's
James clear calm slash newsletter but
but yeah you can just james clear calm
anatomic abaca mental that'll have it
all for you
cool good talking you man great thanks
Richard peace
[Music]